Vladimir Poutine une nouvelle fois fait
preuve de fermeté et de détermination
avec cette déclaration si l'Occident qui
a imposé de cours de sanctions à Moscou
pense que la Russie va reculer c'est
qu'il ne comprend pas la Russie le
président russe a précisé que le pays
est prêt à discuter d'un statut neutre
pour l'Ukraine et qui n'atteindra les
objectifs de son intervention militaire
qui se déroule comme prévu fin de
citation le problème c'est le pouvoir
comment le contient autant d'années
comment on peut se dire que ce n'est pas
une pathologie et qu'on n'a pas
peut-être une petite quéquette
à un moment donné je reste au pouvoir
aussi longtemps et que à un moment donné
alors que je suis peut-être dans la
folie et que je suis en l'usure absolue
de déclencher une guerre mondiale
regardez bien le visage de Joe Biden qui
a déshonoré l'Amérique jamais john
Fitzgerald et Nini n'aurait laissé faire
ça c'est à dire que 42 millions
d'Ukrainiens 70% sont des chrétiens et
le pape resto Vatican au lieu d'aller à
Kiev et de dire toi je représente le
Christ je représente le Christ est-ce
que vous croyez que Jésus serait resté
au Vatican
à My God
l'Ukraine participera au concours de
l'Eurovision cette année c'est du 10 au
14 mai à Turin en Italie et alors
forcément on aura alors quand je dis on
aura ça sera des centaines de millions
de téléspectateurs mais les yeux rivés
sur le groupe kalouche Orchestra les
voilà et le groupe kalus
tu n'as pas de titre ni de grade mais tu
dis tu quand tu parles à Dieu j'ai
l'impression que Marine Le Pen veut me
pécho merci
avec des paroles dans la chanson qui
résonnent avec l'actualité je
retrouverai toujours mon chemin vers la
maison même si toutes les routes sont
détruites attention
je sais pas pourquoi je dis attention
parce qu'il y a aucun danger
ça c'est tout ce que j'aime alors vous
avez peut-être constaté une fine couche
de poudre
ocre orange sur votre voiture sur votre
terrasse ou sur vos plans alors c'est
normal c'est un vent de sable venu du
Sahara qu'on appelle le sirocco qui a
recouvert la France et l'Espagne hier et
regarder la même atteint jusqu'à nos
massifs montagneux ce qui fait que la
neige n'était plus très blanche en
Haute-Savoie alors c'est un phénomène
qui n'est pas rare mais qui n'est pas si
courant quand même chez nous et qui
devrait durer encore quelques jours
certains internautes ont une lecture
plus politique tout ce sable du Sahara
qui envahit la France c'est juste pour
énerver Eric Zemmour dit un internaute
d'autres revisitent la fameuse formule
ton père est un voleur il a volé tout le
sable du Sahara pour le sur ta bagnole
météo avec Valérie Maurice
alors c'est ça qui compte bravo Casto
chez vous il y a vraiment tout ce qui
touche
alors oui non
vous avez bien compris que là une petite
période de récession est en train
d'arriver pouvoir d'achat augmentation
de l'essence la direction elle a bien
raison on ne claque plus d'argent
bêtement dans des jingles juste avant de
parler de ça
vous être parlé depuis
SMS c'est comme si vous voyez un ex
pas vraiment on a quand même non c'est
une image voilà après l’œuf sur la tête
d'Éric Zemmour la poudre rose sur
Valérie Pécresse d'un échange avec des
entrepreneurs à la défense la candidate
LR et a été aspergé par deux militants
d'un collectif anticapitaliste ils ont
aussi visé le patron de la Confédération
des petites et moyennes entreprises
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé
c'est tout simple
Marine Le Pen vous nous dites que
l'islam est compatible avec la
République vous avez dit ça
j'adore les les personnages mangaient
mauvais c'est très excitant enfin je
veux dire jouer quelqu'un qui a raison
de penser ce qu'elle pense qui dès
qu'elle passe ou comme elles sont bons
ça ne m'intéresse pas du tout ça ne
m'intéresse pas du tout parce que
ce qui m'intéresse dans la vie c'est
évidemment les aspérités les gouffres
c'est ça qui donne notre humanité je
vais te faire comprendre la différence
entre lutter contre l'islamisme et
s'attaquer à des jeunes filles qui
devaient pas avoir plus de 15 ans et qui
voulait faire une photo avec moi
qu'est-ce que tu aurais fait toi tu
n'aurais arraché son voix
j'aurais pas pris un selfie avec elle et
d'autres choses
exclamation d'une autre d'un autre
siècle quelle est cette exclamation un
peu vieillotte est-ce un saperlipopette
ou deux wesh un saperlipopette de wesh
est-ce que dans justement le sport est
votre mode de vie et de fonctionnement
d'hygiène de vie oui oui moi je veux
alors c'est exemplaire à votre tenue à
votre agent franchement vous avez 60 ans
je crois non non je dis ça c'est pas
péjoratif
[Applaudissements]
j'adore ton matraque vous êtes super
c'est toujours agréable
je me suis intéressé à vous mais
contrairement en préparant l'émission et
c'est vrai que vous n'avez pas de
premier homme si vous êtes élu non ça
fait trois ans vous cherchez l'amour non
vous cherchez pas non vous pensez le
trouver non vous serez seul vous serez
seul à l'Élysée oui
oui
dans les derniers mandats moi je ferai
pas de faux bienvenue dans l'univers
étrange des animaux hybrides c'est le
nom d'une page sur les réseaux sociaux
ready tous des internautes à
l'imagination galopante s'amuse à créer
des mélanges d'espèces animales à la
manière de créatures mythologique
Photoshop en plus ainsi na qui a l'ours
aigle le bourdon mouton et le canard
serpent à ce petit jeu les combinaisons
sont infinies fort je crois que personne
ne dira le contraire ses effets spéciaux
sont vraiment extraordinaires merci
Chris d'ailleurs Chris ça vous
ennuierait pas de me ramener à la
normale s'il vous plaît
enfin la normale je veux dire comme
avant bien sûr papi pas de souci
[Musique]
waouh c'est parfait merci Chris je me
sens moi-même